now I'm going to do some canceling right
but you've got to be cautious for
instance this part here do you remember
when we first introduced inverse trig
okay I actually made a big deal to say
sign or a sign ago say of sine alpha
right this is equal to alpha but only
sometimes remember why only sometimes
they don't simply despite being invest
funds that are just magically cancel
each other out for what values is a work
now this is a very great so it's a while
back you can you can draw it out if you
want what you're going to get if you
were to graph sine inverse of sine and
something you'll get this graph does it
have any points yes we're done from won
2-1 a straight line so it does look like
you get the same function when you get
it back it's just like y equals x okay
but only works with in here because for
instance that's put some angle in there
okay put in sapé pie on I don't know
platitude okay sine of pi/2 is Sun
finder is one sided verse and that's
okay right but if it's a really huge
angwin there like 15 pie or something
like that actually what is sign of 15
pie you're not talking that's on 15
pints come on sides a simple function
wash goes up and down and up and down
and up and down every multiple of Pi
side should be equal to 0 right see
you're excited 15 pioneer right which is
which is 0 okay so when you take this
item most of that you've got sine
inverse of 0 which doesn't take you back
to 15 pie doesn't what does it take you
back to just takes you back to 0 right
because that's the first with the
closest value to the origin that gives
you that result so this is not always
true it's only true for let's do the
next line shower- sir
onto this statement is only true when
you have this domain okay mr. moon
between minus one to one that's the
domain of show us okay in other words
minus 2 2 2 now I don't mind you we're
not finish it by the way but that kind
of bothers me the fact that you're
getting an sr but it's only your answers
only the legit answer for some values of
x like in other places our answers wrong
but that turns out to be no problem can
anyone tell me why we missed something
very very early on yes aha that that
domain restriction this one here right
it lies up um not very coincidentally
with the domain Michigan here ok so in
fact what we really should have done is
taken note of it there ok so get some
get a big red green purple whatever
color you used to highlight things ok
and take that right down ok domain
restriction you have a choice you can
mention it here ok you can mention it
right at the front or you can mention it
later on when you really need it which
is when you're simplifying a sine
inverse sine thing ok when do you think
is the best place to do it given that
you have a choice when when would you
mention it first or later earlier
although I think earlier why why is that
a good idea it doesn't matter aha so if
you're like me you will get through all
these lives of working and then by this
time it's a bit like ah when they make
you do the warm-up for PE you like you
go to the one point seek to do a warm-up
you do you want and then you're like to
exhaust it's actually running 1.6 ok so
by this time your brain will be so fried
I will bear most of you will forget this
ok so it's better to mention it right at
the beginning when you see a square root
when you see a fraction you should
notice the domain restriction okay um
secondly with any other question where
we've got two main restrictions we
always mention them at the beginning
right so I think it's probably good
practice
so we're fine good that sign of cyber
civility just turns into x 1 spoon all
right this guy cause of sine inverse
that yeah I'm gonna have to draw it okay
but the question is draw what now
remember sine inverse of something right
just refers to an angle yes so this is
an angle that belongs to some triangle
right so okay I would draw a triangle
here what should I put in it well I've
got an angle that I'm interested in
let's just call it theta for lack of a
bit moon because you know they don't
write and sine inverse of this angle is
exile to excellent food so where do X
into and it's going is diagram opposite
and hypotenuse right X on too ok
excellent too now when I do sine of this
angle sine theta it's no problem cuz
just xl2 again that's why I have this
but if I want cause then what do I have
to do i need this other leg down here
right so Pythagoras so this is the
square root of 4 minus x squared you can
go check it out if you want ok all right
so therefore cause of this mess it's
just cause of that angle which is
adjacent on hypotenuse so the square
root of 4 minus x squared all over 20 k
plus my cool then be constant ok all the
actions have any over here is justly all
right now after i tidy this up i'm
basically done because now everything in
terms of theaters it's back in terms of
the variable i was interested in so this
guy is still hanging out the front these
twos cancel cancel cancel so you get
minus X square root of 4 minus x squared
on 2 plus constant exhale ok so that was
I told you it was more work even though
it seems like let's go because it wasn't
definite you gotta watch out for all of
this number one I think the domain
restrictions are
your cash to be careful and number two
you got to draw a triangle cuz otherwise
what enough to do this did with this
thing there's not much you can do okay
and they will not have set this as a
final note song that you've got a 5-foot
okay maybe one last thing don't forget
your constant as you're doing all of
this stuff over here and then you'll
forget to write plus it